So we analyzed our
one-dimensional collision
where we had an object 1 moving
with some initial velocity,
object 2 also moving with
some initial velocity.
And after the collision,
we just arbitrarily
said object 1 is moving
this way and object 2
was moving that way.
And we called that
our i hat direction.
In this collision,
we assume that it
was a frictionless surface.
And there were no
external forces.
So momentum is constant.
Now what about energy?
Well, we know that if there
is no external forces, then
in principle there could
be no external work.
However, during the
collision, we've
established different
types of collisions.
We said elastic
collision is when
we are assuming that the kinetic
energy of the system-- that's
K system final minus
K system initial--
is 0, the statement that the
kinetic energy is constant.
We have an inelastic
collision in which
delta K system has decreased.
And that can come from some
deformation of the objects
during the collision.
Heat is generated.
Some sound, some
other source of energy
in which energy is
always constant,
but the kinetic energy of
the system could diminish.
And we also talked about
a super elastic collision.
And in this type of
collision, the kinetic energy
of the system has increased.
Now that's a little bit
tricky in terms of what
we're calling our system.
But imagine that when
these two objects collided,
there was some type of
chemicals on it that exploded.
And so that was
some chemical energy
that was converted into
extra kinetic energy.
So in order to make a
model of our problem,
we have to beforehand make some
assumptions about the nature
of the collision.
Now for our
particular collision,
let's assume that the
collision is elastic.
So we have two
conservation principles.
We have that the kinetic energy
of the system is constant.
And we've already said
that because there's
no external forces, the momentum
of the system is constant.
So now we can write down our
kinetic energy condition.
We have m1 V1-- now here, this
can be a little bit tricky
how we're going to write
this, because remember
kinetic energy is
a magnitude squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2 initial squared
equals 1/2 m1 V1 final squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2 final squared.
Now because a
component, although it
can be positive or
negative, in one dimension,
if you square the component,
you get the magnitude.
So I can also write
this equation--
and I'm going to divide
through by the halves,
cancel all those-- as 1x initial
squared equal to the magnitude
squared plus m2 V2x
initial squared equals M1
V1x final squared plus
1/2 m2 V2x final squared.
And we've already
canceled all the halves,
so we have no half there.
Now given this equation--
we'll call this equation
1-- we can also had
our momentum equation,
which I'm going to
write down as 2, m1 Vx
initial plus m2 V2x initial
equals m1 V1x final plus m2 V2x
final, reminding
us of our condition
of the constancy of momentum.
So now, if you look at this,
if we're given the masses, all
the mi's and we're also
given the initial state
of the system, V2x
initial, then we
have two equations
and two unknowns.
And we can solve algebraically
for V1x final and V2x final.
And by determining the
signs of these components,
we can figure out the actual
final state of the system.
So this is going to end up
involving a quadratic equation.
And what we'd like to do now
is show an alternative way
that gives us another kind of
conservation, another principle
to analyze these one
dimensional collisions.
So we'll begin that.